There's nothing colder than your
shoulder when you're dragging me along
like you do.
Like you do.
And then you switch up with no warning
and you kiss me like you want it. How
rude. How rude. But I kind of like it
anyways. I don't mind if this is going
to take a million days. I know you'll
come around to me eventually.
If you sit back, relax, enjoy my
company, my company.
Once you know what my love's going to
feel like, nothing else will feel right.
You can feel like moon beam ice cream,
taking off your blue jeans, dancing at
the movies, cuz it feels so
magical, baby. Cuz you know, you know,
my love is so
baby. you.
My little heart to get. Baby, I want to
give you the world. Not saying you got
to chase me, but I wouldn't mind it if
you give me just a little bit of
something we can work it with. But all
you do is push me out.
But I like it anyways cuz I think I'm
getting closer to you every day. I know
you'll come around to me eventually.
Just sit back, relax, enjoy my company.
Oh, baby, trust me. Once you know what
my love's going to feel like, nothing
else will feel right. You can feel like
moon ice cream. Taking off your blue
jeans, dancing at the movies. Cuz it
feels so
baby. Yeah.
Heat.
Mystical. Magical. Oh, baby. It's
mystical.
Mag.
Hey friends, I hope you enjoyed watching
that flow session. as much as I enjoyed
creating it. Uh, and I have good news.
If you really dug those LED contact po
that I was using in the video, uh, you
can actually get a set for yourself at a
discount. That is you can use the promo
code drexfactor with a zero instead of
an O at checkout over at ultraoy.com to
get 10% off your own pair of those Orboo
Pro LED contact po. Big thank you to
Ultraoy for sponsoring this video and
giving me a reason to go out and flow
every month. And speaking of thank yous,
uh, I have special thanks owed to the
friends of the channel. Uh, big thanks
to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca, Flowfests,
Flow Toys, Pyroer, Light Toys, and
Ultraoy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible. You can learn
more about all these amazing companies
and the work they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video. And thanks are also due
because this video and all the videos on
this channel would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on
Patreon. And specifically, I want to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now. Thank
you. You all rock. If you out there
watching would like to get your name in
the credits or access to a whole host of
other awesome rewards, you can do that
by heading on over to my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and signing up. I'll leave a link down
in the description as well as up in the
cards. Thank you so much for watching
and if you'd like to check out more of
my flow sessions, I'll include a link to
a playlist of them both down in the
description as well as up here on
screen. Take care. Get out and flow
yourselves today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon.
Peace.